all right doug yeah doug where'd you
grow up where are you from originally i
was born in the bay area we moved around
a lot we moved to reno tulsa
santa maria
northern kentucky
and
northern kentucky is where i went to
high school
and then i
couple years
after high school i
did some college
went to
northern kentucky university
went to
um
brigham young university and utah valley
university and palomar college
palomar was where
i uh i decided that college wasn't for
me like i
i got the i got the social experience
from it and i liked meeting new people
and
talking to new people and stuff but the
class and
structure of it all was
i just wasn't feeling it and i was like
i'm gonna go out
in the real world
[Laughter]
make some money and then just pave my
own path and
well now i'm in a homeless shelter
what uh what was your childhood like
with your parents it was it was okay
like
we watched the simpsons every sunday
night like that was our church you know
like if if we weren't uh
if we weren't together like the rest of
the week sunday nights we'd get together
and like
uh
every night before it started my mom
would like yell around the house like
you're gonna miss the couch kids you're
gonna miss the couch
because the couch gag at the beginning
you know you got it
and um
so your childhood was fairly good it
sounds like it was all right yeah
yeah
we uh
we didn't have
um
over our means like money-wise
and
but my parents
jobs like allowed them to
move us around just kind of wherever
and
my dad would like learn everything there
was to learn at one job and then he get
bored and then he's like well let's move
to a bigger
market
so then
i can learn more
and so yeah we moved around a lot i get
the question like were you an army brat
or
a lot but nope just uh
he's a tv news producer my mom's a nurse
so
times where we maybe
would have needed to go to the doctor
my mom was there to
patch us up and stuff but
brother younger sisters
and then yeah after school and like
a bunch of jobs i've had
i've had like
38 39 jobs
and i'm 37 wow and so and some of those
jobs i kept for over a year
like the movie theater
that job was [ __ ] awesome
regal cinemas
but then they got bought out by some
company called danbury cinemas and the
way they got that name was there's a guy
named dan and a guy named barry
and they
became business partners and we were
like let's start at movie theater
so
after you're
out of school yeah do you have
relationships marriage kids thing like
that
yeah when i was in living in san diego
county which is where i went to palomar
college
um
i met someone
and we dated and then we got engaged and
then we got married
and it kind of felt like it was all on a
track you know like
[Music]
and
so
we got married and
it just
wasn't the best
for both of us and
so we went to like marriage counseling
and stuff and a couple months after that
called it
and then
divorced
then i was living with some roommates i
picked up this piano off craigslist
yamaha cp70 it's like this
electric acoustic
traveling touring piano and if the rumor
is true the person i got it from
got it from someone who got it directly
from eddie money
and i'm like that's pretty cool
uh
there's a couple keys missing there's a
c missing and a d missing and those are
my initials flipped dc i'm like that's
also kind of cool i got to get those
strings replaced at some point because
dancing around those keys um
so today you're down here on skid row
so so today you're down here on skid row
yeah
are you in a homeless shelter how long
you been here
um
about
three or four months
and um
i ended up here because
there was one night where i parked my
van
and
i
like something was guiding me that night
and i
i had smoked some
weed laced with meth
and um
and i was just on one like i
i kept i felt like i was being guided by
voices
and just like
walking and walking and walking on this
journey to where the destination was i
don't know and then i ended up in front
of this spot
and i was like meditating and
it was awesome and i felt like i was
talking to like everyone in the entire
universe
at one point
and
and i was like this is beautiful this is
amazing and then after that
uh
i still felt like i was being guided and
i was walking and i was so [ __ ] tired
i have chronic lyme disease so i'm
really weak all the time like i i'm 37
but i feel like
on the inside i feel like i'm like 85
so there's like a lot of or
you know 105. i don't know there's a lot
of strong 85 year olds out there but
uh
just feel really weak and i'm just
walking and walking and then um
i saw this fire
and there was just kind of people
walking around and
didn't seem like much of an issue
and then there was this like little ramp
right in front of the fire like someone
had built it
from the from a high school shop class
that like looked like a shoddily put
together ramp but it was right in front
of the fire and
something
excuse me
something kept telling me
you know what would be a really cool way
to end this day
if i could jump over that fire right
there
and the fire was like
maybe about this high
and i
i had the presence of mine to be like
well i'm not gonna try and jump over the
middle of the fire because then i'll
definitely catch up fire
but i could jump over the side of this
fire
and [ __ ] if i was wrong
these are the skin grafts
ouch
from when i was in the hospital
after i left everything
left the van and like
um this is where they like cut
the skin to make the skin grafts for the
rest of my legs and
goes all the way down to my toes but
it was it was wild there was emts there
immediately
and they were like putting me out
and
they were like cutting my clothes off to
make sure i didn't have any other burns
and
i was in the
the emt
ambulance
and i apparently got driven to cedar
sinai hospital that day but i don't have
any recollection of that i just remember
waking up
in a different hospital
and i had these bandages all over my
legs and they were like we had to
put bandages on the parts of you that
basically wouldn't go out wouldn't stop
bleeding
and we're gonna have to do skin grafts
and we're gonna need your signature and
i'm like well
[ __ ] if i won't stop bleeding if that's
the only way then
hopefully
hopefully that'll
do it and it's healing but it's scarred
you know like i'm
this was recently this was pretty recent
this was in the last
uh four or five months oh wow yeah
and um
[Music]
i'm not going to do that again
don't play with fire everyone
so what so what are your drugs typically
do you get burned
what do you use most often uh
i i smoke weed a lot like that can be
like a day to day thing
and then i really really love shrooms
like the first time i had magic
mushrooms
it was incredible there's three front
three friends we were all together we
were hanging out but we were all on
different levels of the high
so one friend was like on the ground and
just kind of like covering themselves up
with a blanket and just kind of doing
living in their own
uh high and then one friend was
like
up and down and like back and forth from
their room and like at one point they
took their shirt off
and that but while they were in their
room and then they came back out to the
place where we were all hanging out and
me and my other friend who was on the
floor were laughing and he was like you
guys laughing at me
and we were like no i mean we just think
it's funny because we were in here and
all this you had a shirt on and then all
of a sudden you didn't like that was
just kind of funny
um but
i if i had if i had the money to do
mushrooms
every day i probably wouldn't do it
every day but every week
hmm
that would be amazing i
like i saw them i saw the ceiling like
billowing
as if it was
a layer of reality and i stood on this
chair and i was like
i know
the ceiling is solid
but i see that it's moving like water
and it looks like i could put my hand
through it if i tried and i know that i
couldn't
but the fact that it looks like that is
really [ __ ] cool
and there was this poster on the wall i
used to host this comedy show
out of the duplex duplex comedy suplex
and i
like people have talked about
all the time when i heard about mushroom
experiences like the walls looked wet
like every all the paint looked wet and
everything
and
i saw some of the some of the ink on the
poster and it looked like it was kind of
running a little bit i was like huh
maybe
when we're on mushrooms we can see
gravity in motion
and i was like that's [ __ ]
and people say don't look in the mirror
when you're on mushrooms
i was looking in the mirror for a minute
and then i was like oh [ __ ] okay i gotta
look away from this mirror i didn't see
anything
crazy or anything but i was like oh okay
like through the looking glass like
there's another
there's another me on this on the other
side of this glass and
i was just like all right i'm not going
to look in the mirror anymore so you
enjoy mushrooms for their
hallucinogenic claws right that's that's
what you get off of it yeah
and like
because seeing [ __ ] is cool as long as
you can be like i know this is a trip
like i went into it
as an adult and so i was just like all
right this is going to be what it's
going to be and i'll figure it out along
the way and
talk to my friends while we're doing it
and
all of a sudden i had all started having
all these ideas i started tweeting them
but i didn't tweet that i was on
mushrooms i was just like
oh you know would be such a cool idea
for a superhero team oh it's these guys
and it's going to be called this
and all we need is money to make it
happen
give us your
money
and no one did
but
um
those ideas are still still up here i'm
like those those
those characters could still become
comic book characters at some point
so the the idea of maybe applying
yourself towards some goals that you may
have had or something like that
just kind of gets
yeah thrown by the wayside well uh i
don't know because if you're going to be
high on mushrooms you're probably not
going to be able to do much else well i
did get all those tweets out there which
was pretty cool and i i think i have
them downloaded somewhere
and i could turn that into something
to make a more cogent idea of like what
the comic book will be
um
but i got a lot of i've been uh man
as of creative projects i've got a lot
of them and like some of them i'm like
all right table that for now but i gotta
do this right now or like okay i'm gonna
start editing this and like
get this together and make it more
reasonable
like
scripts and like
drawings like i started i wrote this
script for a cartoon
well i was just like
super [ __ ] high it was weed but
i was i was just like whoa that would be
crazy that would be crazy
and then all of a sudden i had a script
and i was like oh [ __ ]
okay
okay a cartoon uh
i don't know how to animate
i guess i'll have to learn how to
learn how to animate like i i tried to
show it to a friend of mine and they
came up with a couple
character designs and
and
the character designs that i came up
with
are different than the ones that they
came up with but their designs are way
better than mine because they like
they've
they've worked in animation a little bit
and i'm just like all right well
shoot maybe i could have made that work
if i
wasn't like i don't know
it's not how i imagined it
but
getting together
getting anyone together for a creative
project is a struggle because at the
beginning of the creative project you're
like
well
i have work or well i don't have work so
i need to try and find work
because this isn't paying right now
it could pay later
and
you just have to put a lot of trust in
yourself and a lot of trust in who
you're working with to make sure you can
get the job done and
sometimes it works out and sometimes it
doesn't
so for my my belief is that everything
we do there's a negative and a positive
aspect to it yeah so doing mushrooms
you you like the
little ride you go on right yeah what
what are the negative
the negatives um you know the only
negative i would say
is if you don't eat it paired with
something else that can like cover up
the
taste because they're [ __ ] like it's
[ __ ] shrooms you know like you're you're
eating shrooms that were grown in [ __ ]
so there's like
[ __ ] molecules in there or something and
it's like cow [ __ ] and like that's what
makes it work and
if you just eat it without anything else
you're gonna taste that [ __ ] taste in
your mouth for
i was gonna say [ __ ]
for a while
even brushing your teeth and then your
toothbrush is gonna smell like it
pair it with peanut butter maybe cook it
down saute it with something
um
make it part of a meal
but that's the only negative i could see
from mushrooms like i
i bet i bet though like if you're doing
them every day
then your your perception of reality
might shift a little bit where you're
like is this just rooms or is this
really happening i suspect there's
something
else involved in doing
uh
hallucinogenic that
especially if you do it regularly yeah
that you'll you'll pay some kind of
price yeah i'm not saying you're going
to have brain damage i'm not saying
anything like that i'm just saying it
might
your ability to apply yourself towards a
goal might be it might it might strike a
different pathway in your brain but
you'll also come up some really great
creative ideas yeah so you gotta trade
off
and you gotta wear both of those yeah
you got the trade-off of like all right
i'll do this occasionally
maybe not every day but when i do it i'm
probably going to get some ideas and i'm
going to be ready for them and i'm going
to write them down or tweet them out or
post a blog or make a video and
get those ideas out there
because while while i was thinking of
these
characters for this comic book i was
like
i can see i can like see the pages
turning and i can see the panels and
stuff and i can see it all lining up and
how
this character would maybe meet that
character and like
this would happen over here and
uh
but
since i didn't have the presence of mind
to like write any of it down i was like
well twitter that's an open forum maybe
people will respond to it
i think i got a couple likes on some of
them but
nothing big
nothing viral
nothing where you see those tweets and
you're like
67 000 likes
are there that many people on twitter
tonight are there that many people on
earth
doug what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
um
i'll tell you what gratitude leads to
growth
positivity and patience will get you a
really long way
and love and self-love like
very important lessons that i've learned
through a lot of trial and error a lot
of
negativity i used to have a lot of
negative [ __ ] on my twitter and i like
not i i was trying to do the thing where
you just delete all the tweets and like
have still have all the followers and
following and what i accidentally did
was i deleted the whole entire account
so everyone who i was connected to was
like oh well [ __ ] me then i guess i'm
like no i didn't i was just trying to
get rid of the tweets
ugh because there was just like
negativity on there where like there was
this one tweet that i got that got
around a thousand likes
and when that was happening i was like
oh [ __ ] this is something negative
though
this is something negative though i
don't want it to like blow up like uh
but then yeah later on i had the
presence of mind to log back into the
twitter and just be like all right i'm
starting fresh
ground zero like
here's a new account
gratitude growth positivity patience and
love and occasionally i'll still yell on
there but it's like
a little more vague or
just uh getting my feelings out
but
yeah man like
talking about shrooms again
the the when
when we were all coming down off of the
high
i was like damn
i don't know if i could do this every
day
but every week or maybe even like once a
month and just
double whatever i did that day
the experience is beautiful
it's like
uh
i mean and i i guess it depends on where
you get it and who you're with and what
your
circumstances are like i've heard to not
do them if you're in in a rough place
but to do them if you're
with someone you trust or people you
trust and like friends
and good vibes maybe have weed there on
the side that you're smoking while the
while the shrooms are doing their work
and
it's it's something else man i
love it well thank you so much for
sharing your story of course thanks for
having me good luck with uh good luck
with getting off uh off of skid row
thanks i i oh can i plug a couple things
real quick nope okay